Hallo ihr Lieben!
Heute geht's süß daher! Wir machen nämlich etwas richtig süßes aus der türkischen Küche.
Und zwar machen wir - wie heißt es noch mal? -
Paşa Sarması mit  Kadayıf. Also ihr dürft euch darunter folgendes vorstellen:
Wir haben einen Milchpudding, den wir auf Engelshaar ausbreiten.
Engelshaar, das sind diese Teigfäden, die zeige ich euch gleich auch.
Und ich beginne auch direkt. Ihr findet ja wie immer die ganz genauen Mengenangaben
unten in der Videobeschreibung. Und Hamza, wir beide starten jetzt direkt, ne?
Also ich hab jetzt hier mein Engelshaar, was ich jetzt so grob durchschneide,
weil es klebt dann schon ziemlich zusammen
und die Fäden sind auch relativ lang.
Daher einmal grob durchschneiden und dann geb ich's auch schon in die Pfanne.
So, das Engelshaar muss auch noch so ein bisschen auseinander gerupft werden, weil das schon ziemlich
zusammengepresst ist, also macht das einfach in der Pfanne direkt.
Und dann geben wir Butter mit dazu und das ganze soll jetzt richtig schön - ja so
rötlich-braun werden damit's auch was für's Auge ist
und damit's auch richtig schön knusprig ist und gut schmeckt.
So, das nimmt jetzt auch ein paar Minuten Zeit in Anspruch,
also ihr müsst schon so mit 5min rechnen bis es hier richtig schöne Bräune erhält.
Und jetzt geben wir Puderzucker dazu weil ich das schon gern ein bisschen süßen möchte.
Aber keinen Kristallzucker, Puderzucker kann sich jetzt besser auflösen
und sobald es sich aufgelöst hat, gebe ich alles auf mein Backblech.
Es ist ganz wichtig, dass ihr die Kadayıf Masse jetzt total gerade und gleichmäßig verteilt.
Das Blech, das brauchen wir jetzt erstmal nicht. Wir machen jetzt den Pudding. Und dafür
habe ich hier Milch in meinem Topf und da gebe ich jetzt folgende Zutaten hinzu:
natürlich Zucker für die Süße, dann habe ich hier Mehl und Vanillepuddingpulver
und wenn ihr mich kennt, dann wisst ihr dass ich zum Vanillepuddingpulver
immer noch Vanilleextrakt mit dazu gebe,
weil mir das sonst viel zu wenig Vanillegeschmack ist und es ist ja auch
künstliche Vanille da drin. Und hier haben wir dann echte Vanille, damit aromatisiere ich das noch mehr.
Und dann rühre ich das um, sodass es  klümpchenfrei ist
und anschließend wird's unter Rühren einmal aufgekocht.
(H: *unverständlich*)
Ohja!
So, jetzt ist der Pudding schön dick, ich habe den Herd ausgeschaltet
und gebe jetzt Butter dazu, das lasst ihr in der Hitze einfach schmelzen
und rührt's dann unter.
So und jetzt geben wir den Pudding noch im heißen Zustand
- das ist sehr wichtig, damit er eben nicht fest wird und ihr ihn verstreichen könnt -
geben wir ihn jetzt auf die Kadayıf Schicht. Und das am besten gleichmäßig
damit ihr so wenig wie möglich verstreichen müsst.
(H: Wo ist denn deine Schürze?)
Die habe ich jetzt einfach weg getan.
(H: *lacht*)
Es ist nämlich echt warm hier
mit den ganzen Lichtern! So, und jetzt - oah ist so statisfying, das ist mein Lieblingswort! -
Schaut euch das mal an!
Ich liebe Pudding!
So, beim Verstreichen mit der Winkelpalette darauf achten,
dass ihr wirklich vorsichtig verstreicht und ganz langsam mit ganz viel Gefühl.
So und jetzt muss es eigentlich nur noch auskühlen
ehe wir es aufrollen können, das ist ganz wichtig. Entweder bei Raumtemperatur,
dann dauert's erheblich länger, oder im Kühlschrank.
Ich bin jetzt so schlau - Achtung, Werbung! Ich werde jetzt die Bügel hier einfach
einfahren von meinem Backblech, dann passt das nämlich wunderbar bei mir in den Kühlschrank
und dann dauert's auch nicht soo lange. Dann kann ich gleich schon mal weiter rollen
oder aufrollen.
(H: Wie schlau du bist ey!)
(H: Unglaublich!)
Jaa! Also bis gleich, ciao!
So, das war jetzt bei mir für ca. 45min im Kühlschrank,
konnte jetzt richtig schön auskühlen und fest werden.
Und jetzt nehmt ihr euch ein Messer oder so ein Teigrad und schneidet euch Streifen
und die Streifen werde ich dann nochmal halbieren,
damit ich eben nicht so große Röllchen habe, sie sollen ja auch so richtig mundgerecht
und portionsgerecht sein. So, ich schneid jetzt einfach mal drauf los.
So, ich rolle jetzt weiter vor mich hin, verabschiede euch aber schon mal.
Ihr könnt natürlich bei der Deko variieren, ich nehm' jetzt ganz klassisch Pistazien .
Das finde ich immer so typisch türkisch und generell typisch orientalisch.
Was ich auch gesehen habe, was viele machen, sind Nüsse noch mit rein tun, zb Walnüsse.
Ihr könnt auch Kokosnuss da noch mit rein tun bevor ihr es aufrollt.
Ich mag's jetzt lieber pur oder ihr könnt auch Soßen obendrüber geben,
Schokosoße z.B. ganz wie ihr möchtet.
Und ich wünsche euch jetzt einfach mal ganz viel Freude beim Nachmachen
und ich freue mich jetzt schon über eure Fotos auf Instagram,
da markiert ihr mich dann fleißig, dann kann ich es direkt reposten.
Und ansonsten noch einen wunderschönen Tag und bis zum nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen!
Tschüss!